buongiorno a tutti mi presento subito
sono il dottor guglielmo scilla
psicologo psicoterapeuta specializzato
nell'interpretazione dei sogni e nelle
truffe oggi cosa faremo oggi prenderemo
in esame alcuni sogni che mi sono
arrivati da parte della community che
ormai mi segue e mi stima da molti molti
anni prima di iniziare però ci tenevo
invitare tutti quanti voi a condividere
qualora abbiate il piacere i vostri
sogni in modo da renderli materiali di
analisi delle prossime puntate
dell'interpretazione dei sogni di frode
[Musica]
signora
[Applauso]
e lì
[Musica]
buongiorno
il dottore la sta aspettando una volta
ho sognato di rimanere incinta nel
ginocchio dopo una puntura aspettavo un
bambino nel ginocchio
beh caro mauro ritiene fortunato potevi
sempre essere appunto nel deretano
in tal caso il parto sarebbe stato
sicuramente più interessante
un altro paziente scrivere quello più
brutto che ho fatto e che mi porto
stampato a fuoco nella memoria l'ho
fatto prima del test di ingresso di
professioni sanitarie
risvegliamo del mio letto in piena notte
sentivo una voce che mi chiamava avevo
paura è andato in camera dei miei
genitori dove trovavo tutta la mia
famiglia in forma di bambole di ceramica
con i loro occhi spenti e spalancati mi
fissavano dal letto e la voce infestante
mi parlava cara giulia credo che sia
abbastanza semplice analizzare questo
sogno ti stavi cagando sotto ciao come
ti permetti io molte volte ho sognato di
essere colpita da uno tsunami
una volta sono andata oltre vedevo
questo tsunami avvicinarsi così decido
di prendere un gommone ed andare ad
avvertire le persone
la nostra eroina ma quando arrivo lì mi
rendo conto che c'era un invasione
aliena in corso ei ero batman entro di
nascosto in una navicella cerco di
capire dove portino le persone e vedo
che entrano tutti in una stanza vado è
un alieno mi colpisce con un raggio ma
non faceva male e anzi sentivo che mi
stavano irradiando con la conoscenza
dell'universo e ti giuro che per un
attimo nel sogno sapevo qualsiasi cosa
poi mi sono svegliata aver dimenticato
tutto
sicuramente l'immagine dello tsunami
cara
non ti firmi ti sarai dimenticato pure
quello l'immagine dello tsunami
sicuramente ha un richiamo fallico in
qualche modo questa eiaculatio
prepotente però una cosa nota
all'interno del tuo sogno che voglio
assolutamente chiarire
sappi che sia all'interno del mondo
onirico che fuori non sai un cazzo e
questo non cambierà mai
un bacio una volta ho sognato di farlo
con mio fratello più grande ti scrivo da
un profilo appena creato per la vergogna
nel volerlo ammettere disclaimer
il ragazzo omosessuale in un dichiarato
che prova ribrezzo al pensiero di una
cosa simile
percepisco estremamente confuso se non
sbaglio credo che ci abbiano fatto un
telefilm che più o meno è durato tutti
gli anni 90 ma voglio darti una parola
di conforto
sei un porco ero a letto e mia madre mi
appoggiava letteralmente un pesce vivo
sul comodino esclamando a colazione c'è
questo stamattina
io ho presa dall angoscia di mangiare un
povero pesce vivo che ho fatto ho
cominciato a parlare col pesce gli ho
detto fra che allegra l'opzione non
voglio mangiarti senza acqua come fai a
campare nel sogno oppure pensato se devo
sopravvivere uccidendo un altra bestia
tanto vale che campi ha riso insalata
per sempre non avesse fatto mio fratello
questo sogno
stupisce si alza e noto che quadrupede
si quadrupede salta giù dal comodino e
si dirige in cucina ma vedo che arranca
perché sta oramai morendo lo prendo in
braccio e con un lancio degno dei
migliori giocatori di baseball lo butto
dalla finestra dritto dritto in un fiume
che avevo comodamente in giardino se
riesce a spiegare questo tanto di
cappello e il pesce ha sicuramente una
valenza in qualche modo fallica
e la voglia di cazzo è sempre infinita
federica comprendo che sul comodino come
colazione o fuori di una finestra la
nicchia vada sempre benissimo con una
giovane ragazza curiosa una volta ho
sognato che partoriva tartarughe non
voglio sapere cosa kakà di george a
scrivere una volta la piccola sognava il
busto di mio fratello davanti ad uno
sfondo nero cioè stava nel buio però io
vedevo la sua faccia che era senza occhi
quindi buchi neri
al loro posto e bocca aperta sempre nera
e vedevo mille insetti che gli uscivano
dalla bocca occhi orecchie e naso che
facevano giri sulla faccia di mio
fratello
dopo i miei tre anni passati a monaco a
prendere una specializzazione da
entomologo la ricordi aver fatto lo
stesso sogno quando sono tornato a casa
per le vacanze natalizie
sognavo il viso orribile di mio fratello
enrico cosparso di tutti questi
lepidotteri ricordo che la cosa più
brutta era di svegliarmi nel rendermi
conto che il bisogno fratello erano
ancora peggio di quello del sogno per
preve disco ancora se ci penso marta
amato una nuova paziente ciao gu come ti
permetti 3000 e sogni assurdi che fa la
mia ragazza per poi uccidere a pugnalate
nella gobba sua zia galluccio ce n'è uno
spesso ricorrente lei che deve prendere
un volo in aeroporto senza
un'indicazione precisa e puntualmente
c'è la sua famiglia che per un motivo o
per un altro le fa perdere il volo
aiutaci tu ad interpretarlo perché sta
diventando un tormento esiste un termine
scientifico proprio per definire la
famiglia della tua ragazza [ __ ]
giulia a marsico una volta ho sognato di
partorire gamberetti seduta sul pattern
fallico
non so se posso aiutare ma è stato tanti
anni fa durante il periodo di natale non
ho mai capito perché ho sognato ciò a
volte l'assenza di bidet e può portare
effettivamente a degli odori vaginali
estremamente forti che possano in
qualche modo ricordare tutto quelli che
sono materia di studio
degli ocean ology quindi il consiglio in
realtà di utilizzare omat e rinfrescanti
mento late e fidati che al posto dei
gamberetti la prossima volta usciranno
vigorsol ciao come ti permette proprio
stato trasognato erano vicini ad una
casa fatta di pietra e legno che poi ho
scoperto essere la tua
mentre passeggiavamo i raccontavi di amy
fatto notare che nel sottoscala esterno
c'era una pecora con il impolverato e io
la vigna eccola qui dove è finita sotto
casa mia del sottoscala quindi ok e non
capivi di che fosse di sua madre lo sto
benissimo mi sono svegliata con
un'incredibile voglia di arrosticini e
si maligna fa questo effetto sul mio
spesso di dover andare in bagno e tutti
i bagni che trovo anno le porte aperte
oppure non hanno proprio le porte sono
bagno orrendi dove mi può vedere
chiunque
capisco che tu appartenga a quelle
persone che hanno difficoltà a lanciare
dei siluri organici quando non si
trovano all'interno delle proprie
abitazioni ma ti consiglierei di fare
un'analisi un pochino più a fondo cos'è
che ti porti dentro di sporco che
vorresti nascondere vorresti togliere
dalla tua vita eliminare evacuare
ma che amy così tanto di lasciare libero
perché perché paura che chiunque
potrebbe vederti che cosa potrebbe
essere chiarite o forse questo tanto di
capelli ecco che ti distrugge
completamente il viso e che nella tua
foto di profilo tutto si riveda tranne
che il tuo viso un sorriso c'è ma
l'abbiamo verticalizzato v come ti
permetti di a1 che faccio la quando sono
piccola sogno di galleggiare nel nulla
un nulla tutto bianco e silenzioso tipo
una scena dopo la battaglia sulla neve
di mulan
in questo nulla sono caldissime del
tutto ovattato manco il mio
psicoterapeuta sa che dire
immaginavo che una
gallinelli
sapesse minimamente in che modo porsi
davanti a un sogno invece così lampante
lapalissiano oserei dire io credo che tu
sia in questo momento invece molto
scollegata dalla realtà la tua paura di
provare di vivere vivere a colori e di
bere timpone di desaturate tutto quanto
e filtrare della realtà tanto da
distorcerla completamente e fai bene
ricordo invece in passato di avere avuto
a che fare con quest'uomo un mio
carissimo amico giulio cesare giulio e
lui prendeva tutto così seriamente
maniaco del controllo e aveva bruno o
bruto ora non ricordo che era comunque
un bruto o un bruno ecco e gli dissi
occhio questo ragazzo perché non mi fido
mangiando quest'uovo alla cuoco emesse
fatti i cazzi tua presi quel
l'insegnamento alla lettera luino un
trapano gigante con forma fallica che
scava la terra vicino a me e io che
impaurita cerca conforto nei miei
genitori anche se il vero sogno del ter
pretare sarebbe quello in cui harry è
protagonista
considerando che sogni trapani riescono
facilmente a immaginare cosa tu abbia
sognato con me
ricordo una doccia che ho fatto insieme
a questo mio amico che era un pochino in
imbarazzo una volta soppesate diciamo le
dimensioni del mio membro rocco si
chiama lui così intimidito ma detto nel
dubbio tra panelle tutte io da allora ho
capito che effettivamente il trapano nei
sogni ha una valenza fallica come
direbbe il mio amico rocco un black
decker nel cassetto dovrebbe essere
veramente l'alleato di ogni ragazza che
si rispetti come vuole il tempo quando
ci si diverte è venuto anche a trovargli
la piccola menu per qualsiasi
informazione andate pure a iscrivervi in
segreteria sono sicuro grandes istante
non avrà problemi ad attivare per voi la
campanella delle notifiche lasciate una
recensione positiva anche perché credo
che lo possiede tre altro se non volete
che venga a trovarmi dei vostri incubi e
infine se volete anche voi che il
sottoscritto interpreti i vostri sogni
non esitate a lasciarli qua sotto tra i
commenti
un caro saluto dal dottor guglielmo
scilla alla prossima è ricordata chi
dorme non piglia pesci ma prende e ci fa
dormire da dio
un saluto assumino andiamo a cagare
sulle letterine che ci arrivano
lei
[Musica]
no